explíquenos por favor cómo los
enfrentamientos en las calles están
impidiendo que los niños y niñas tengan
acceso no solo alimentos sino también a
servicios de higiene y de saneamiento
lo que vemos como situación en el
terreno en las calles de Puerto Príncipe
pero también en el resto del país es un
aumento de la violencia de calle de la
guerra entre las pandillas lo que impide
que las mamás los papás puedan llevar a
sus hijos a sus hijas en los centros de
salud no pueden salir a comprar
argumentos no pueden ir a buscar agua
potable y esos elementos esos
ingredientes desde hace meses y meses
ahora conllevan una situación de
deterioro de la situación humanitaria y
un aumento significativo de las
desnutrición aguda grave de estos niños
estamos hablando de un aumento de 30% es
enorme en menos de un año y son niños
desnutridos que viven en una situación
de supervivencia su vida está en riesgo
su vida está en peligro si no reciben
medidas humanitarias direc si no reciben
asistencia humanitaria directa y
precisamente como parte de esa
asistencia humanitaria unicef está
pidiendo 17 millones de dólares para
combatir la desnutrición si bien hay
medidas urgentes por tomar Qué acciones
piensan ejecutar para atacar las causas
más estructurales de la desnutrición y
que están ligadas con la pobreza y con
otros determinantes sociales
pero hay que salvar la vida es posible
sabemos que en el contexto actual es
posible salvar la vida de estos niños no
cuesta tanto lo difícil es Cómo llegar a
acceder a las infraestructuras de salud
para brindar apoyo y que sus niños y
estos niños puedan recibir la asistencia
humanitaria eso es el primer paso pero
luego es también atacar las raíces de la
pobreza de la violencia reabrir las
escuelas para que los niños y las niñas
puedan romper este círculo vicioso de
pobreza y de violencia que los maestros
puedan volver a la escuela y enseñar sin
tener miedo y eso es el portfolio las
actividades programáticas que llevan a
cabo unicef tanto salvar vidas pero
también atacarse a las raíces de la
pobreza y de la violencia en Haití y muy
brevemente Usted cree que logren
recaudar este dinero teniendo en cuenta
que lo que unicef ha pedido para Haití
de esto Solo han recibido el 15%
Porque mucha gente han perdido fe y
esperanza en Haití pero hay que darse
cuenta y yo lo vi yo estuve en Haití
hace unos meses vi Cómo podemos cambiar
la vida de estos niños Cómo podemos
salvar con unos dólares salvar la vida
de un niño desnutrido es posible hay
ventanas de oportunidades cuando se para
la violencia no esos equipos pueden
hacer llegar suministros al
infraestructuras de salud pero
necesitamos este dinero y necesitamos un
dólar dos dólares es suficiente para
salvar la vida de un niño y una niña en
el contexto actual en Haití No hay que
perder esperanza